[Musique]
bonjour je suis Eric dandel le directeur
du cfmbtp nous sommes centre de
formation d'apprentis et de stagiaire
donc sur l'ensemble de métiers de la
construction de bâtiments et travaux
publics du CAP au BTS
[Musique]
Vincent de molinis je suis chargé
d'affaires pour l'entreprise de peinture
linofaria situé à Élancourt
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis 1994
[Musique]
cette relation entre l'école le CFA et
l'entreprise c'est la base même de
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage c'est un
temps en école un temps en entreprise le
jeune apprend autant d'un côté que de
l'autre aujourd'hui nous avons 500
apprentis du CAP au BTS et donc en face
500 entreprises et 500 formateurs en
entreprise qu'on appelle les maîtres
d'apprentissage nous recevons les jeunes
environ deux semaines par mois pour
venir travailler chez nos clients sur
des chantiers intérieurs et extérieurs
pour des opérations de préparation et de
finition
l'intérêt du partenariat CFA entreprise
donc de l'apprentissage c'est que ça
permet aux jeunes à l'école d'apprendre
toute la théorie d'apprendre les normes
et en entreprise effectivement
d'apprendre le métier en situation
réelle pour nous l'intérêt c'est d'avoir
des jeunes qui soient prêts au monde de
l'entreprise dès la sortie de l'école et
l'obtention du diplôme
dans une période où nous recherchons
plus de 40 000 nouveaux compagnons dans
le domaine de la construction des
bâtiments des travaux publics le
partenariat apprentissage c'est-à-dire
le partenariat entre CFA et une
entreprise à vocation à se développer de
plus en plus l'idée la solution au
problème de l'emploi il est la solution
aux problèmes de la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée le partenariat débouche
souvent sur une embauche et quoi qu'il
arrive c'est toujours le jeûne qui
choisit la fin
[Musique]